oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and today we've gathered to
remember the attacks of September 11
2001 now thirteen years past we were
young and we did not understand and now
we know that with this evil some 3,000
men and women passed from this world
we've gathered here today to remember
the tragedy which we can never
comprehend but which nonetheless reveals
in each remembrance and in each peg of
loss the goodness of human life
and it is good to remember we have long
enjoyed the greatest blessings of this
life the love of friendship and family
education for its own sake communion
with God and the freedom to choose the
fullness of what we are to be on this
earth in this nation these blessings
abound implicit in the recognition of
tragedy is a primal affirmation human
life is sacred and beautiful and good
and even in the face of incomprehensible
senseless evil evil that abides and are
forever open wounds we know this to be
true Almighty God lest we forget
we stand before you in sombre reverence
as we remember the unconscionable evil
of 13 years ago this day